[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la maternité la naissance l'embryon les
procréations médicalement assistées
c'est un peu par défaut qu'il y est venu
et pourtant c'est devenu son monde
l'univers de toute sa carrière le combat
de sa vie la vie justement il a aidé à
la donne et des milliers de fois
amandine par exemple premier bébé
éprouvette français le 24 février 1982
en fait notre invité à révolutionner la
médecine obstétricales le premier bébé
issu d'un embryon congelé en 86 c'est
lui le premier bébé médicament en 2011
s'est lui aussi son obsession c'est
d'aider les femmes les couples qui n'y
arrive pas à faire un enfant certains le
qualifient d' apprenti sorcier se sont
ils un peu apprentis sorciers on va lui
poser la question bienvenue dans un
monde un regard bienvenue professeur
rené frydman et merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation dans ce lieu magnifique
assez méconnu du sénat qui est le dôme
tournant est-ce que vous vous sentez un
peu apprentis sorciers
apprentis en tous les cas je ne sais pas
mais vous savez on est confronté
constamment à des questions auxquelles
on cherchait réponse est dans ce sens là
il faut innover et en fait c'est un
problème philosophique 1 est ce qu'on
est prêt à innover avec un certain
nombre de risques effectivement on va
essayer de les minimiser au maximum
d'être transparent dette informatif
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya un côté comme
ça je dirais de tentes et l'innovation
et c'est ça qu'il faudrait perdurer est
ce que dans vos équipes dans vos propres
équipes il est arrivé qu'on vous dise
stop non là tu vas trop loin ou attend
un peu alors d'abord je vous remercie de
parler d' équipe parce qu'effectivement
c'est à moi seul c'est toujours avec une
équipe en particulier clic aux
biologistes
et psychologues et ses terrasses est une
équipe oui il ya eu des divergences
il ya des personnes qui ne voulait pas
continuer qui sont partis d'ailleurs
il y en a d'autres qui mettait des
réserves alors l'avantagé d'être chef de
service et grand manitou a salué tous
deux de faire passer la conviction de
gré ou de force mais ce qui fait votre
différence c'est quoi alors c'est plus
d'audace vous voyez plus loin vous voyez
plus grands vous y avez réfléchi écoutez
d'abord on est en est à une échelle
mondiale
si on reste dans son franck est fausse
et ça va pas et sur le plan mondial et
quand même eu pendant ces quarante
années à une agitation intellectuelle
importante
donc quand vous voyez qu'il ya des gens
qui sont pas les derniers nés ou des
hurluberlus qui font des choses ça vous
renvoie à vous à vos propres réflexions
peut-être que le précédait des fois ils
les suivent et donc voilà c'est un c'est
un échange c'est vraiment un échange
important moi j'ai énormément voyagé
j'ai vu beaucoup de gens dans des
situations différentes des patientes
différente de toutes les conditions
sociales de toutes les religions de
voilà et voilà il ya des permanences de
désir de vivre une maternité une
paternité et il ya des moyens pour y
arriver qui était révolutionnaire mais
qui méritent quand on opte pour une
nouveauté
il faut avoir un esprit scientifique
c'est à dire qu'il faut toujours évaluer
ce qui est positif qui est négative peut
pas répondre avant de commencer c'est ça
le dilemme les gens voudraient qu'on
disait jamais non il faut mener la
réflexion et l'organisation comme ça
c'est un plan social par exemple c'est
ce qui n'a pas été fait du tout dans le
coup vie de 19 par certains du côté de
marseille kan a annoncé ce que je pense
et mes compagnes mis en place les
protocoles il ya des protocoles qui nous
ont fait marche arrière et faire marcher
à d'autres que nous devons au contraire
amener à poursuivre je disais que vous
étiez arrivé à une spécialisation dans
l'obstétrique un peu par hasard par
défaut c'est vrai c'est ce que j'ai lu
j'ai écris parce que c'est la vérité
c'est à dire qu'en fait moi j'étais à
l'époque avec bernard kouchner médecins
sans frontières au tout début et donc je
voulais faire de l'orthopédie pour
pouvoir être là où il ya des urgences
des traumatologies les voilà et puis je
me suis rendu compte donc en faisant ce
métier est tout à fait audacieux aussi
beaucoup d'autres gens mais dans un
autre genre que ça me correspondait pas
c'est à dire que voilà c'était un peu du
bricolage
artistique mais moi c'était pas tout à
fait mon
mon truc et donc j'ai fait ce qu'on
appelle la chirurgie quand on fait pas
du dur les eaux ont fait du mou et dans
le mouv j'ai commencé par faire une
écologie de la gynéco qui est toute
l'intervention chirurgicale sur les
ovins sur les utérus et c est donc j'ai
été confronté ben j'ai envie de dire que
j'étais confronté au moyen-âge français
à l'époque ça remonte pas tellement je
suis pas si vieux que ça mais quand même
dans les années 70 ou 75
accueil du râle pas d'enregistrement du
coeur du bébé pendant l'accouchement pas
damiot synthèse la douleur des femmes
maximum la paternité la pâte la
parentalité
nono et
je me suis dit mais c'est pas possible
il faut faire autre chose dans ce
domaine et puis bien sûr y avait la
sérénité et la nécessité de dépasser les
gestes chirurgicaux qu'on faisait pour
ouvrir des trompes à l'époque qui se
bouche est du fait d'une infection et
trouver un autre moyen le moyen c'est
pas moi qui l'ait trouvée c'est bob
edwards ce qu'est le prix nobel pour
cela mais il sauf que j'étais parmi les
premiers à le lire et surtout à faire
tilt en me disant mais c'est ça qu'il
faut faire essayons de comprendre
pourquoi ça devient à ce point une
obsession une mission dans votre vie je
lisais mon histoire c'est la survivance
c'est ce que vous avez dit un jour je le
dis pour nos téléspectateurs vous êtes
nés sous l'occupation allemande dans une
commune des pyrénées atlantiques vos
parents juifs polonais ont été cachés
est ce qu'il y ait un lien à faire entre
ce parcours professionnel cette envie de
donner la vie d'aidé à la donner est ce
que vous dites mon histoire c'est la
survivante ce coup d'essai c'est
toujours très difficile de faire les
causes à effets c'est surtout quand il
s'agit de soin
néanmoins
incontestablement quand vous êtes né à
cette époque là et que vous êtes quelque
part un survivant parce que à peu de
choses près tout d'un coup de chance
vous ne seriez pas là et vous le savez
pertinemment et vous avez perdu une
grande partie de votre famille
vous êtes tourné vers la vie sa seule
façon de survivre en 7 vivre vous êtes
tourné vers la vie et donc oui quelque
part chaque naissance et j'ai souvent
dit est elle ressentie en tous les cas
chaque naissance et une victoire sur la
mort et mais ça je suis pas le premier à
le dire mais en tout cas champ d un de
ceux qui le vivent intensément c'est ce
qui m'a fait que ce moment merveilleux
que j'ai essayé de décrire parfois avec
l'aide de certains
dans des dans des livres plutôt poétique
c'est ce moment par exemple que j'ai
essayé de percevoir dans le regard d'une
femme lorsqu'elle découvre son enfant au
moment de l'accouchement et moi j'ai
toujours rêvé de faire des photos des
yeux des femmes qui deviennent maman
moment à l'instant même fugace parce qu
avant et après et puis ça dure pas
qu'est ce qu'on y voit dans ses yeux
dans ce raid en aval le grand
basculement
la grande émotion et d'émotion qui qui
qui qui surprend tout le monde et ce en
particulier celle qui est inquiétant au
coeur du système à ce moment là et puis
son conjoint il ya une expression du
visage le visage se décompose et se
recompose et quand il se recompose jeune
femme qu'elle est elle est devenue maman
et donc il ya quelque chose qui a failli
du vin la forme de magie quelques chaoui
une forme de magie
votre ami le journaliste serge july a
dit un jour à propos de votre histoire
et de la rumeur selon laquelle les nazis
ne portait pas les femmes enceintes je
le cite cela induit chez rené l'idée
qu'il avait sauvé sa mère depuis il fait
des mères il sauve des maires et des
couples aussi alors c'est un peu la
psychanalyse qu'on fait mais pourquoi
pas ses intérêts sans considérer que
c'est juste mais c'est à dire que vous
savez dans l'histoire on pensait à un
moment donné que alors que beaucoup les
juifs et les juives été raflés quoi
qu'en dise le zemmour même français les
juifs français eh bien
on pensait que les mères celle qui était
enceinte serait protégé ne serait pas
amenée
déportés on ne savait pas où et qui que
quoi comment enfin voilà est donc
quelque part moi je me suis toujours
demandé gym et enfin moi je suis né en
43 donc conçu des bus 43 donc fin 42 des
bus 43 pensez avoir un enfant dans les
conditions d'être cachés tout sa venue
mais c'est quoi cette affaire comment on
peut penser ce à quoi et en fait j'ai
enfin c'est ce que ma mère m'a dit c'est
d'ailleurs y est déjà certain nombre de
cousins cousines qui sont nés dans cette
période là paradoxalement aussi cacher
c'était une façon de penser que ça
protégerait les femmes ce qui était
évidemment erronée mais ça on a su que
plus tard et sentir le fil vous avez
protéger les femmes ou les andes en mer
oui encore une fois je dise c'est
compliqué de tout cas on peut voir une
un éclairage comme ça j'ai lu aussi
qu'un cabinet de sages femmes avaient
été créés dans la maison où vous aviez
vécu à soumoulou alors ce boulot c'est
un petit village donc des basses
pyrénées où mes parents étaient protégés
par deux familles et une en particulier
les casenoves
nous revoyons toujours la quatrième
génération ont des liens forts et un
jour une de vos confrères
faisait un reportage et j'étais avec mon
frère à soumoulou et maison mais on va
les voir la maison vous êtes né qu'il
maison se fait banal qui n'a aucun
intérêt à l'embauché d'un événement
qu'est ce que vont donc on va les voilà
pas d'intérêt quoi êtes vous aussi venez
venez alors je suis allé et en fait
effectivement une sage-femme dans cette
petite pièce venait de s'installer il ya
quelques mois et mon frère lui a reconnu
un pelé parce qu'il est plus âgée que
moi il a reconnu un peu les les lieux
moi évidemment pas et
l'incroyable c'est que voilà c'est
qu'ils avaient
alors je rappelle encore sans être
exhaustive évidemment les prouesses
médicales dont vous êtes l'auteur ou le
coauteur puisque effectivement ce sont
des équipes le premier bébé éprouvette
en 82 le premier bébé issu d'un embryon
congelé en 86 la première naissance
après un diagnostic préimplantatoire en
2000 qui permet d'éviter la transmission
d'une maladie génétique à un foetus le
premier bébé médicament en france même
si vous n'avez pas l'expression et vous
préféré appeler bébé du double espoir
classe cc en 2011 est ce qu'il y à une
première fois qui vous a marqué plus que
les autres un nom un vrai dire à chaque
fois c'était
certaines bloc
point par point à arriver et et s'il
fallait résoudre ce problème parce que
c'était à chaque fois c'était quelque
chose qui permettait de d'ouvrir de
nouvelles portes elle est équivalente et
ce sont des enfants vous avez suivi à
chaque fois
non petit première fois l'épreuve oui
les premiers bien sûr c'est souvent
souvent on a tissé des liens avec les
parents et donc du coup après les
enfants puissent grandir et y compris
eux mêmes devenir parents donc vous
pensez amandine oui par exemple amandine
qui est venu deux fois maman et que j'ai
que j'ai vu de près bien sûr dans cette
transformation et puis d'autres enfants
aussi mais vous avez le plus le plus
étonnant c'est toujours dans des
endroits un peu anachronique pour
rencontrer quelqu'un qui vous dit mes
docteurs c'est vous qui avait accouché
touré accompagné tout ça bien sûr
qu'avec le temps le disque dur s'efface
un peu et vous savez plus très bien qui
que quoi surtout quand vous voyez des
hommes sait plus à quelle femme s'était
et jeudi mais quand même j'en ai fait
des choses et le fêtait ses que ben 40
années vous savez c'est un peu jour et
nuit quand même hein c'est un métier qui
est très prenant passionnant j'ai jamais
rechigné moi aller à 2 heures du matin à
5 heures du matin parce que je vais y
avait une politique
c'est plus tout à fait la même chose
aujourd'hui mais voilà moi j'ai vécu
j'ai j'ai vécu avec avec intensité avec
bonheur avec ses enfants qui sont nés
grâce à vous il qu'est-ce qui vous
disent ah c'est compliqué il faut pas
leur demander quelque chose d'ailleurs
je suis toujours un petit peu mal à
l'aise parce que c'est en moi on t'en
dis tiens tu sais c'est le monsieur qui
alors parce que ils ont un papa ils ont
une maman je dirais voilà c'est une
belle histoire et et ils ont usé car qui
dit il ont du mal à comprendre le
pourquoi du comment surtout quand ils
sont encore peu petit et moelleux
finalement la relation que j'ai c'est
surtout avec le coupon avec la mère ga
sur en plus plus mais parfois
intensément aussi avec le père les
enfants je les regarde je les regarde
avec une certaine distance oui parce que
j'ai retrouvé les propos d'une femme que
vous avez aidé michel ducurtil qui avec
son mari et vous a vécu sept ans d'échec
un bébé mort né vous leur avez ensuite
permis d'avoir une petite fille qui
s'appelle lola louer qui est né en 2002
c'est plus tout à fait une petite fille
et cette femme dit de vous il a été le
roc sur lequel nous avons pu nous
appuyer au long de ces dix ans il nous a
éclairé guider et soutenue avec humanité
bienveillance chaque jour en voyant
notre fille nous mesurons la chance que
nous avons eue de le rencontrer pour les
parents vous êtes un sauveur un miracle
oui enfin c'est c'est l'histoire qui est
miraculeuse je viens dans lequel je joue
avec d'autres un rôle sans doute mais je
dirais savez enfin quand vous connaissez
cette
espérance qui n'aboutit pas cette
souffrance que qu'elle entraîne et que
d'un seul coup soit parce que y'a un
geste médical qui est fait soit parce
que voilà il ya des conditions qui ont
changé et qui fait que
l'arrivée de cette grossesse de ce désir
d'enfant concrétiser c'est quelque chose
qui a des racines extrêmement profond
d'ailleurs vous ne connaissez pas une
femme en particulier maintenant les
hommes aussi qui si vous le lancez sur
sur la grossesse sur l'accouchement sur
le désir d'enfant vous en avez pour la
soirée c'est clair
c'est vrai aussi que j'ai lu c'est que
des maires déposé des roses en deux
devant la porte de votre bureau à
l'hôpital béclère est-ce que vous avez
aussi fait face à de l'opposition
a de l'hostilité alors à des insultes
vous aller flirter avec les interdits
parfois vous le disiez tout à l'heure
vous avez commencé une époque où voilà
vous pratiquer des ivg qui n'étaient pas
légaux voilà alors par exemple dans ce
combat général un peu pour l'autonomie
de la femme qui passe par la
contraception par l'accès à l'ivg est
médicalisé qui passe à la fécondation in
vitro qui passe à l'auto conservation
des ovocytes va tout ce qui donne à la
femme la possibilité de ne pas subir
cette maternité mais de la désirée et
donc d'investir dans ce désir d'enfant
oui j'ai participé j'ai eu la chance
d'être dans cette trente glorieuses 40
muriel où tous ces choses là existaient
et puces arm a correspondu je me suis
donné un à coeur joie
maintenant
bien sûr qu'il ya constamment des
oppositions mais constamment la
contraception élevé des oppositions les
vg n'en parlons pas on était les
signataires les 300 médecins consigne
est on était presque mis au ban de la
société médicale en ce qui concerne la
fécondation du tour je vous rappelle que
l'église catholique dans sa sagesse a
condamné la fécondation in vitro et des
hôpitaux pas très loin d'ici qui était
sous obédience catholiques ont dû fermer
à l'époque leur leurs activités de pma
pendant avec des couples y as qu'elle le
plus de couples traditionnels on va dire
donc est toujours eu alors le diagnostic
génétique pré implantatoire c'est à dire
la possibilité d'analyser des embryons
avant de les remettre
c'est un combat qui malheureusement
aujourd'hui là quand on se parle n'est
toujours pas passée en france alors que
dans la plupart des pays il est passé ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que 60% des
embryons que nous remettons dans
l'utérus apprennent que dans la finition
ne vont pas se développer on le sait
mathématiquement on sait pas lesquelles
ce qui fait qu'on fait des gestes
inutiles des souffrances inutiles parce
que s'ils se développa soit 5000 un
fausse couche et ça va être encore une
fois un échec alors qu'on pourrait les
preuves pour le corps de la femme
exactement donc vous voyez on allait les
caisses qu'on ouvre torque y compris des
ministres nous attend mais vous êtes sur
la voie de l'eugénisme ça me fait quand
même un peu
un peu voir ça un peu différemment que
ce qui est dit parce que c'est
simplement de reconnaître les embryons
qui n'ont pas de développement possible
et pas du tout de choisir des embryons
avec telle ou telle caractéristique ce
que je me refuse de faire bien entendu
voilà donc sur les oppositions mais
alors vraiment au sein au sein de même
la médecine au sein des scientifiques au
sein de la société c'était important
justement j'ai un document à vous
montrer qui est complètement en lien à
ce que vous dites c'est juste qu'il est
un petit peu anciens c'est une archive
il nous est proposée par les archives
nationales d'un document d'avril 1988
écrit par michèle barzach ministre
délégué à la santé à la famille sur les
procréations médicalement assistées
diagnostic prénatal et michèle barzach
ses sept ministres qui va officialiser
la mise en place d'un encadrement des
pma limité à 74 le nombre de centres
autorisés à pratiquer les nouvelles
techniques et limiter son recours à la
réparation de l'infertilité chez les
couples hétérosexuels seulement c'est un
document qui va provoquer une fronde de
médecins vous vous rappelez oui je me
rappelle très bien c'était un pas en
avant vers l'institution réalisation de
cette pratique avec des ânes encadrement
et c'était nécessaire parce que il faut
effectivement faire évoluer les esprits
montré que ont fait pas tout et
n'importe quoi d'ailleurs en france
depuis 40 ans je ne connais pas je ne
dis pas tiens n'a pas eu mais je ne
connais pas de dérive tellement si vous
voulez c'est une spécialisation qui est
cadré encadré observer et qui a une loi
skhira parce que tous les pays n'ont pas
de lois de bioéthique nous sert
quatrième quand on a alors des fois elle
va pas assez loin dans tous les cas elle
existe et elle elle donne une certaine
un certain encadrement mais voyez
aujourd'hui par exemple ou la quatrième
loi de bioéthique vient d'ouvrir aux
femmes seules aux femmes en couple
homosexuel aux halles à la possibilité
d'autoconservation ovocytaire pour des
jeunes filles le problème clé c'est que
ça c'est obsolète c'est à dire qu' il
n'y a pas suffisamment de centre
qu'ils puissent réaliser cette
congélation ovocytaire
7 ce dont deux qui est trop cadré et si
on continue comme ça je veux dire dans
six mois on est dans le mur mais dans le
mur c'est à dire que les femmes pour
continuer à aller à l'étranger vont
continuer à faire de livres et du sperme
par internet et des pratiques illégales
derrière la porte du cabinet vont
reprendre voulait dire qu on a avancé on
n'est pas allé assez loin voilà un
bateau mais on a fait semblant d'avancé
pas semblant je pense mais c'est comme
si on voulait pas voir la réalité pour
trieste tout le monde est vraiment il ya
200 médecins de la reproduction en
france tout le monde est sur la même
ligne
quels sont les verrous vienne d'où ces
verrous qu'est ce qu'ils veulent alors
on est dans le temple de la gestation
ici dans le sénat ba écoute et voilà le
verrou il vient pas au sénat le
parlement également un les deux les deux
assemblées mais si vous voulez en france
le fait de faire des lois de bioéthique
est une bonne chose mais quelque part
elle renvoie souvent des positions à des
engagements politiques et des
combinaisons politiques et des
associations politiques et non pas sur
le fond du problème quand on vous entend
se demande si vous avez des limites
est-ce que vous en avez oui lesquels et
bien par exemple voyez j'ai toujours été
totalement opposé à la gestation pour
autrui gpa est relation par beaucoup
dont on a beaucoup parlé par le moins
heureusement
parce que je pense que là on se met
toujours du côté de ceux qui vont en
bénéficier
c'est à dire c'est comme si vous
demandez à des propriétaires d'esclaves
s'ils sont pour l'esclavagé ou contre
c'est pas à ces gens là qui ont fait de
comparer ces femmes qui sont volontaires
pour porter un enfant pour un couple à
des esclaves si elles le font bien
volontiers ben qu'est-ce qui vous prouve
que le font bien volonté à le fond
économiquement c'est comme la
prostitution alors on peut être libre de
se prostituer c'est vrai mais on tombe
aussi dans des mafias et le problème de
cgp assez con il ya aussi des matières
qui sont constitués parce que je ne sais
pas si vous avez déjà lu le contrat
qu'une femme qui décide de porter un
enfant pour quelqu'un d'autre doit
signer et bien gla sa vie qui est
complètement bloquée dans ce nom ce
qu'elle fait dans ce qu'elle demande
lorsqu'elle se déplace dans ses
relations sexuelles donc c'est une vente
location tout du moins du corps et moi
je trouve si vous voulez que ce n'est
pas comprendre ce qui se passe dans le
lien entre l'enfant et la femme qui le
porte mais c'est surtout ne pas voir la
violence qui est faite aux femmes parce
que il ya une espèce de gpa idéal dit
éthique qui n'existe pas qui n'a jamais
existé et qui n'existera pas mais tout
le monde se réfère à sa fin ce les
partisans et puis à la réalité qu'est ce
qui se passe au vietnam mais est ce qui
se passe en inde et est ce qui se passe
dans les pays de l'est où les femmes
sont le corps des femmes est
commercialisé et banalisé vous avez
d'autres limites être mère après
cinquante ans après 60 ans on peut
imaginer qu'un jour ce sera possible
d'un point de vue médical d'un salaire
salaire des femmes qui ont accouché 72
ans c'est une limite pour vous c'est là
on va trop loin oui enfin je pense qu'il
ya une règle générale qui doit donner
des limites général mais après il ya du
cas par cas voyez pas ce que je pense
que alors je dis pas d'aller sûrement
pas d'aller jusqu'à 70 ans mais j'ai à
la paralympienne un décret qui vient de
sortir limitant 45 ans le la pratique et
plus pour les hommes à 59 ans alors
laissez moi juste vous dire pourquoi que
je trouve ça vraiment pas parfois pas
correct un homme de 60 ans bien sûr que
c'est tard pour avoir un enfant bien sûr
qu'il faut qu'ils soient informés qu'ils
aient un risque d'anomalies comme la
femme de 40 ans est aussi un risque
d'anomalies pour pour l'enfant mais ça
lui de prendre la cae de précision et
surtout la femme elle a son mot à dire
si elle elle désire un enfant avec un
homme qui à 60 ans je veux dire bien
informées c'est à eux de décider si l'on
arrive un paradoxe comme on l'a
d'ailleurs dans l'insémination post
mortem seul essai a été refusé dire
qu'un couple qui est des embryons
obtenus par fécondation in vitro si le
mari vient à décéder la femme ne peut
pas envisager d'être mère avec les
embryons qui existe par contre elle peut
laisser des à quelqu'un d'autre et elle
peut maintenant se tourner vers une
banque de sperme et utiliser un sperme
de donneur
voilà il ya des incohérences qui mérite
quand même qu'on travaille un peu mieux
un peu plus profond au cas par cas et
qu'on fixe pas les choses avec des a
priori comme celle ci qu'est ce qui
guide vos limites alors c'est le fait de
d'utiliser quelqu'un d'autre a son
propre projet c'est le fait d'aliéner
quelqu'un d'autre son propre projet où
c'est le fait d'aliéner ou de chosifier
l'enfant qui va naître et de lui faire a
priori de décider pour lui d l'hôtel
caractéristiques physiques ou
psychologiques
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que j'ai été
d'emblée aussi contre le clonage caylar
l'auto reproduction j'étais membre de la
délégation française à l'onu contre le
clonage malheureusement ça pas été votée
ce qui montre que c'est bien compliqué
parce que c'est toujours un
assujettissement tout assujettissement
de l'enfant ou d'une tierce personne
qu'ils participeraient à ce projet
d'enfant est quelque chose que l'on doit
repousser
j'ai des photos à vous montrer pour mr
friedman
la première si celle ci que vous
reconnaissez peut-être de gouy gui prix
nobel de la paix est revenue en 2018
gynécologue congolais lui aussi il voue
sa vie aux femmes il est surnommé
l'homme qui répare les femmes pour son
engagement contre les mutilations
génitales
pratiqués sur les femmes en république
démocratique du congo vous connaissez
vous vous inspirez mutuellement oui
alors je il sauve pour ces rencontres et
puis on l'a félicité bien entendu parce
qu'ils aient le courage de se lancer
dans cette réparation effectivement des
femmes qui sont victimes de viols
systématiques qui sont des actes de
guerre qui sont vraiment qu'ils
détruisent totalement bien sûr les
femmes et les familles et les clans et
donc il est il est tout à fait
remarquable d'abord parce qu'il a et
fort mais il est une humanité et les
nourritures sur lequel voilà on peut lui
mettre un piédestal j'ai une autre photo
à vous montrer là aussi elle est censée
vous dire quelque chose vous l'avez déjà
un petit peu abordée médecins sans
frontières dont vous avez été membre
fondateur avec bernard kouchner
qu'est-ce que ça évoque pour vous
qu'est-ce que ça
vous a apporté dans votre vie ce que ça
fait le militant que vous semble être
quand on vous entend aujourd'hui mais
écoutez oui c'était surtout au début une
période où on découvrait le monde en
découvrait les horreurs du monde
d'ailleurs dans des endroits un peu
éloigné et on s'est rendu compte que
voilà que ce soit batoko vietnam que ce
soit maternité qu'on a fait à en
envoyant des sages-femmes à djamena que
ce soit le tremblement de terre de du
nicaragua le besoin d'aider son prochain
dans les situations d'urgence maintenant
c'est devenu des institutions à l'époque
c'était une bombe de zoulou
qui était parti alors c'est en même
temps à double tranchant
parce que quand on s'installe dans
l'aide humanitaire permanente tri jouer
la situation dans différents camps c'est
en même temps ça en piste la situation
ça veut dire que vous avez des regrets
et des choses que vous regrettez
notamment dans sinon c'est pas des
regrets parce que je pense que c'était
important à un moment donné de pouvoir
témoigner de pouvoir faire cela ce
qu'était sa briser les tabous la croix
rouge pourtant célèbre est importante ne
faisait pas ce genre de situation ça a
fait bouger les choses il y avait le
droit d'ingérence sur lequel peut-être
on revient aujourd'hui mais qui quand
même était un moteur très important
par contre il faut évoluer c'est à dire
que
l'accent doit être mis sur la formation
des locaux c'est en créant des
personnels médicaux paramédicaux sur
place et en se retirant là on a réussi
la mission si on reste est conscient qui
sait quelque chose qui va pas une
dernière question rené frydman elle est
en lien avec le lieu dans lequel nous
sommes ce dôme tournon au sénat je vais
vous demander à quelle
vertus vous vous identifiez puisque nous
sommes entourés de quatre statues qui
sont tantôt qui sont qui représente des
vertus vous avez la sagesse la prudence
la justice et l'éloquence ou s'il y en a
une qui vous parle particulièrement la
sagesse pourquoi ben parce que je pense
que la vraie sagesse et en même temps
deux d'avancé
et en même temps d'évaluer et de de
savoir se retourner et changer de chemin
éventuellement ou d'en découvrir
d'autres merci infiniment raid et
friedman d'avoir été un a traversé dans
un monde un regard merci à vous de nous
avoir suivis comme toutes les semaines à
très vite sur public sénat
[Musique]